j'accueille gaspard proust pour l aide à
l avis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
'cela fait normale celle là je suis
tellement content que je pourrais te
faire l'apologie littéraire de télé 7
jours
je suis un peu gêné d'habitude je finis
par les bonnes nouvelles oui mais parce
que des fois c'est
c'est rare
ce que des fois il ya des événements
comme ça tu sais on les attend oui et tu
dis ça ce ça a pas venir et je sais que
tous les français partage cette joie et
je suis sûr qu'ils ont tous pris un jour
de congé quand ils ont appris la
nouvelle c'est confirmé nicolas est
innocent
[Applaudissements]
non mais
[Musique]
ça va revenir quoi tu vas aller à lille
d'albi rassemble les grognards et va
marcher sur paris foot dehors le
bolchévique fait dans sa lettre et que
je sais que c'est extraordinaire
non mais c'est un peu un peu d'espoir
parce que tout arrêté de fonctionner
depuis le putsch de l'homme qui faisait
la pluie et le crachin
moi je moi je moi je le savais qu'il
avait rien faire c'était pas possible un
mec de sa classe sa pudeur sarko c'est
un chanoine il n'allait pas escroqué la
momie princesse de la lacc antirides la
squale c'est pas possible et quand bien
même quand bien même il y aurait cherré
du blé à la bête en cours et je veux
dire il a quand même sorti de colombie
ça va quoi
[Applaudissements]
attends
on compte se méprenne pas je ne suis pas
partisan non la gauche depuis un an et
demi elle a fait des trucs vachement
bien aussi elle a perdu toutes les
élections
[Applaudissements]
se préparent j'ai entendu qu'en coulisse
lie cccc branle bas de combat les
brainstormings à morano lefebvre ont
repris des abonnements aux bibliothèques
municipales
balkany et avait acheté du ciment et un
baril vie pour couler fillon d'enfin ça
va être parce que fillon en ce moment et
il est un peu un peu fait tout à
l'envers c'est parce que la procédure
habituelle en politique c'est quoi tu
dis que tu vas être candidat à la
présidentielle ensuite tu rassembles ta
famille politique et après tu racole un
peu les voix du fn au second tour lui
non gps politique détraqué d'abord et
grave du côté du fn ensuite il divise sa
famille politique et la faim indiqué
candidats
[Musique]
mec qui vient d'inventer le moonwalk
politique
politique toujours brignoles cantonales
explosive
le ps n'est pas au deuxième tour et le
fn fait plus de 40% alors la question
que tout le monde se pose mais qui se
cache derrière les électeurs du ps
réponse tout de suite dans enquête
exclusive
bonjour je suis gaspard de la prusse
teulière il se dit socialiste et ne s'en
cache pas ce soir enquête excluante a
voulu en savoir plus sur ces militants
dont les élus ne dépasse plus le premier
tour de scrutin
brignoles d'un côté la garrigue les
oliviers des petites gens qui vous
accueille à coups d'oeufs alors être au
d'être allégé mais brignoles c'est aussi
un visage ce soir
ce sont aussi les associations de
quartier l'engagement bénévole la
défense des citoyens bref le socialisme
ces gens qui se réclament d'un homme
nommé désir sans sucre un nuage de lait
[Applaudissements]
à il entre pour tout le monde
ces gens là on les a rencontrés dans un
lieu qu'ils appellent une assoc
structure étonnante car elle ne possède
pas de but lucratif ouais comme dans
tous les groupuscules radicaux on exalte
le sens représenté par cette affiche
d'une main serrant une rose on leur fait
remarquer que c'est une image qui
rappelle les heures sombres de
l'histoire c'est à dire la vente du
muguet du 1er mai sur deux ils répondent
à bon
tous nos témoins ont eu le courage de
répondre à visage découvert c'est et
gaspard de la proust eu lien en
collaboration avec l'agencé kaka world
cias et flacco slip
bref alors après on peut aussi se poser
quelques questions sérieuses parce que
cette rengaine des électeurs du front
national mais on a déjà tout essayé sauf
le fn c'est dans mon frigo y avait plus
rien alors j'ai bouffé le bac à légumes
assemblée nationale alors un député
imite une poule lors de la prise de
parole d'une collègue franchement c'est
pas plus indécent que lorsque les
députés écouter héros en imitant un
poulpe est mort
alors et puis on a une explication en
fait le député ne se moquait pas de
l'autre député ils étaient juste en
train de traduire pour christian jacob
[Applaudissements]
école un professeur en garde à vue pour
images pédophiles si on commence à
stigmatiser des profs qui s'intéresse
vraiment aux élèves
vacances je me disais en ce moment là qu
est ce qui s qui trouve tout ça à
lampedusa
je suis allé sur le site de sept-îles
n'y a pas grand chose à faire
en termes d'hôtellerie a qu'un seul
hôtel 4 étoiles et encore le wifi et en
supplément
non c'est vrai alors au fond vous savez
c'est des sujets un peu délicat moi ce
qui me frappe chez les clandestins c'est
pas tant leur socle de connaissances
assez bancale en natation
mais leur manque d'exigence ouais bah
oui quand tu vois ce qui à la barre le
problème c'est pas d'accueillir toute la
misère du monde mais au moins un peu de
son ambition c'est tout si je peux
passer un message enfin voilà divers une
chamelle a été volé dans un parc
animalier de l'oise ça sent la voiture
bélier halal
sport paris va accueillir les gay games
2018 bon c'était limite il paraît que
tout s'est joué lors du grand oral
un bel événement non mais
alors c'est un bel événement pour la
télé à part les épreuves de lutte qu'il
faudra passer en crypté
alors bonne nouvelle un oui le nobel de
physique a été décerné à françois
englert et petter et 6 pour la
découverte du boson de x
c'est très important très très important
parce que sans ça au quotidien on
pourrait pas expliquer la brisure de
l'interaction unifiée électrofaible en 2
interactions par l'intermédiaire du
mécanisme de 'brut' anglaise x again
granic qui bleus donc j'ai envie de dire
fait du buzz au boson
alors avec la vie
c'était non stop
on voit les syllabes
d'ici là de maracana sur canal+ et bien
sûr sur canalplus.fr et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu